Good Morning Hank.
It's Wednesday, January 30th and today's video
comes to you in one part.
Part one: I am not a Pornographer.
Hank, you may remember that almost three years
ago my first novel, Looking for Alaska, was
published.
I just found out that Looking for Alaska is
about to be taught to 11th grade english students
at Depew High school, outside of Buffalo,
New York.
Alaska is taught in a lot of English classes
around the country, but it's still pretty
awesome to hear that someone is gonna like,
teach your book in a regular english class,
and people are gonna read it closely and think
hard about it.
So here's what happened.
Because there are a few scenes in Looking
for Alaska that some people find controversial,
the Depew High School administrators and English
teachers got together, and they wrote a letter
saying, 'We're gonna teach this book.
We think it's pretty good.
If you're okay with your kid being taught
this book, please sign this permission slip,
otherwise the kid will read some other book.'
So parents who are cool with their kids reading
Looking for Alaska get to have their kids
read Looking for Alaska, and parents who aren't
cool with it get to have their kids read some
other book.
But there were a few people who weren't happy
with this solution.
These people didn't actually have kids who
are in the 11th grade... but no matter.
They think my book is pornographic and that
it will cause immoral thoughts and actions
in children.
These people believe that no one should be
allowed to read the book, even those people
whose parents signed the permission slip.
*Grumbles*
Now Hank, it's no secret that I like for things
to be about me, but this really isn't.
Still I have to tell you that when you're
told that the novel that you wrote for teenagers
is pornography, you start to feel a little
bit, mmm... mad.
I don't know exactly what it is that bothers
me about that characterization.
I mean, it's not the -ography.
I wouldn't be mad if someone was like, 'We
must get this book out of our classrooms;
it's full of geography!'
Or, 'No teenager should ever have to read
this disgusting work of lexicography.'
No Hank, it's not the -graphy that bothers
me.
It's the porn.
Pornography is designed to titillate.
Hank, I don't think there's a single halfway-normal
person in the world who would find a single
thing in my book in anyway arousing.
There is one very frank sex scene.
It is awkward, un-fun, disastrous, and wholly
unerotic.
Hank the whole reason that scene in question
exists in Looking for Alaska is because I
wanted to draw contrast between that scene,
when there is a lot of physical intimacy but
it's ultimately very emotionally empty, and
the scene that immediately follows it, when
there is not a serious physical interaction,
but there's this intense emotional connection.
The argument here is that physical intimacy
can never stand in for emotional closeness.
And that when teenagers attempt to conflate
these ideas, it inevitably fails.
Hank, it doesn't take a deeply critical understanding
of literature to realise that Looking for
Alaska is arguing against vapid physical interactions,
not for them.
Now Hank, some people are gonna say that kids
don't have the critical sophistication when
they're reading to understand that.
And I have a message for those people.
Shut up and stop condescending to teenagers.
Do you seriously think that teenagers aren't
able to read critically?
When they read George Orwell's Animal Farm
do they head out to the pig farms to kill
all the pigs because they're about to become
communist autocrats?
When they read Huck Finn do they think that
Huck should turn Jim in because the demented
conscience of the community says so?
When they read Waiting for Godot do they think
that it's cool to just sit around and do nothing?
Well, probably they do actually, that one
doesn't really work toward my point.
Now obviously Hank, I don't think that a few
parents should get to decide what the kids
of other parents read in school.
Those parents are qualified to sign or not
sign that permission slip as they see fit.
And to speak frankly Hank, it also pisses
me off when small groups of well-organized
would-be book banners try to take over America's
public school systems.
Now fortunately in Depew, there are a lot
of teachers and school administrators and
school board members who are standing up for
my book and for the right of teachers to teach
it, and for the right of parents to choose
to have it taught to their kids.
But Hank, sometimes these people who make
stands for intellectual freedom can feel like
they're going it alone.
Which is why I'd like to ask from the bottom
of my heart that any nerdfighters that live
in or around Depew go to the school board
meeting on February 5th.
(Info in the sidebar.)
Also, I've written a letter in defense of
the teachers who would like to teach my book.
If you'd like to write a letter, send it to
sparksflyup at gmail dot com and I'll be sure
to forward it on.
Hank, thanks to you and all the nerdfighters
in advance for your emails.